if you want an idea of type address
ambitions who could do worse than
looking here every day a fleet of trucks
and building equipment shoveled tons of
Earth making way for turkeys nearest
airport costing 13 billion dollars it'll
be one of the biggest airports in the
world it's one of three major
infrastructure projects planned by the
Turkish government for the country
centenary celebrations in 2023 it's all
part of prime minister address grand
plan for turkey to become a bigger
regional power this government needs
infrastructure projects because with the
help of this infrastructure projects
turkey's gdp growth accelerates and
that's what that was what that was what
was the case in the last ten years and
that will be the case in the next ten
years with this third airport third
bridge crazy canal project you name it
there will be many projects worth of
more than 200 billion dollars but not
everyone is happy the villages here who
must make way for the airport say
they've been offered a price for their
land way below market value no one would
speak out on camera saying they were
afraid of repercussions
add one has not always dealt with his
critics well last summer a wave of
protests erupted across the country a
standoff over the future of gezi Park
was met with policemen armed with tear
gas and water cannons and claiming all
social media was a menace to society and
Iran tried to silence online criticism
by banning youtube and twitter as voters
go to the polls this weekend we'll see
whether the ambitions of Iran will give
him the presidency and secure at least
five more years in power